foreign
you mentioned Holly's excellent essay on
Sam and one of the things that she says
in that essay is that Sam was an
intellectual hero to her and that twice
Sam had delivered something into the
world that had revolutionized her world
for the better right one of these things
was the questioning of faith and the
other was his treatment of lying
and her point was now she is forced to
part ways with her intellectual hero
because her intellectual hero is doing
things that not only are unacceptable
but don't fit with his own stated
beliefs on these things before without
acknowledging that he's changed but
here's the funny thing about that he's
not the only close friend of ours who
said this
this is a common phenomena
and
um wait he's not the only close friend
of ours who said but she oh okay Holly
is not the only close friend of ours if
I said he that was just uh because the
other friend I'm thinking of is he but I
I think this is a relatively
uh common position where people who got
something from Sam because he was good
at this in some regard
are now stuck in the position of having
to try to a grapple with what was the
stuff that I believed that was important
before if he's now speaking in direct
violation of it he's effectively okay
with a conspiracy
against Trump you know in the 2020
election yeah
um then he's obviously not against lying
so what was this whole treatment of
lying right so what was that but
um anyway what I'm going to argue is if
you are one of these people who
whether you always did or something
about recent history has caused you to
embrace a I'm going to find the best
model and I'm going to stick with it no
matter what right if you do that then a
couple things are true
one you a we can spot that you're doing
it because if you think about how such a
person
would change their mind right you would
have basically a threshold question have
you reached the point where the thing
that you thought was uh
less than 50 percent likely is now more
than 50 likely at which point you would
have to acknowledge a change until then
there's no Nuance as long as you think
it's less likely to be true
um than the competitor we don't see your
changing understanding of anything right
the only thing you're reporting is a
binary it's a binary exactly then the
point is two things one there's this
totally arbitrary Threshold at 50
percent where your opinion appears to
suddenly snap into the other
confirmation that's not how thinking
works right two you're much more easily
gamed right because the thing is how do
you keep somebody who is using this
cruddy mechanism for thinking on your
team all you got to do is feed them
enough garbage to keep them from hitting
the threshold it doesn't have to be
perfect they can have their own private
doubts but the point is you just feed
them enough [ __ ] that they don't hit
50 and flip yeah right and so I think
we're seeing a lot of that I mean for
one thing we know that Sam
proxied part of his understanding to
Eric copel right Aaron topel is
um Kristen Anderson's boss so he has a
perverse incentive that goes back to lab
leak right this isn't somebody you
should proxy to likewise Anthony fauci
right Anthony fauci is uh the person who
offshored the work to Wuhan to get
around the ban on gain of function
research right but why does he show up
here you're talking about him proxying
his or him being a proxy for someone
being a proxy for a lot of people yeah
so you have covid descends nobody knows
anything about it what are you going to
do well I'm going to listen to the
people who know the most about it well
who is that one of them is Anthony fauci
oh good choice you know why because he
stood there with his head in his hands
while Trump was saying crazy things
right so Anthony fauci becomes super
reliable because he's the opposite of
trump and of course that's a brilliant
way to get Sam's attention right so the
point is okay I'm going to proxy to that
guy because he feels the same about
Trump as I do right okay well then
Anthony fauci now has a direct line into
whoever is listening to Sam right so
much better
if we were able to tune into the oh boy
I said these things were safe but now
I've seen a few things I still think
they're probably safe but wow I don't
I'm not as convinced of that as I was
because I've seen a few things that
caused me to wonder right that's the
natural process right
um but no but no public Revelation
instead instead we get some some garbage
excuse like well I'm not going to get
boosted because the CDC lies
and
right but that's that's a non-sec where
it doesn't make any sense it's not an
argument right it's what it is is
evidence of not thinking and my
overarching point is
we saw our entire expert class reveal
that they were not thinking that they
were doing something else at least in
this case and I would argue that
probably that's because it's the habit
of thinking that they got into and if
what you did was uh looked at the com
the competitors to this
and said who are these people and what
exactly do they think they know and the
answer is it doesn't really matter if
they're using the equivalent of
selection to build a model that works
from any starting place they will
quickly outpace a group that has proxied
in the early days of a chaotic situation
where nobody knows anything so the best
model they could possibly have embraced
was bad yep right and the idea that
anybody is sticking with their initial
impression of vaccines of repurposed
drugs of covet origins of any of these
things of the evolution of variants of
any of them nobody could possibly be
making Headway with their initial model
because it just simply wasn't enough to
go on to build a decent model so the
only people the only game in town is
people who's thinking evolves by a
process that really is very parallel to
Natural Selection right I mean that's
really the core point is what do you
trust to build your model right do you
trust
picking the right one you know well that
can work great if a bunch of really
refined models exist and you know none
of them are full of corrupt garbage yeah
but any other situation no I want
something that irrespective of what
model I've ended up in can morph into a
model that works that's what I want and
um and the problem is I think
the uh the propaganda engine was very
good at portraying the process of
evolution as evidence that it was not
valid in other words well if this thing
makes errors
right
ah well and and you know and that's
that's classic media response right who
was it who was it who in part lost the
presidential election because he was
accused of being a flip-flopper is that
John Kerry that would be I think that
was John Kerry yeah so whenever that was
um you know the idea that you've changed
your mind as a politician that that's
going to be the thing that means you
can't hold office like I'm not saying
that John Kerry would or would not have
been an excellent president but the idea
that having changed your mind and being
on record saying one thing and then
later saying a different thing well
that's just too far like that that tells
us like if people can be fooled by that
then we then people can be fooled by
anything yep if if if if they really
believe the change in your opinion
as a politician is should mean that you
should not be in high office well then
we're done we're doomed frankly right
right it is a poison pill for anything
that would function the right way yeah
um so I wanted to uh close out this
section with a couple of observations
one I wanted to point out there's
something that I you've heard me say
many times I think I've said it quite a
number of times on Dark Horse that
um if you say something that is wrong
right if you get something wrong the
process of admitting that you got it
wrong
is very painful for all of us but some
of us are good at why are we good at it
because the pain that you experience in
publicly having to reverse yourself is
such a tiny fraction of the burden that
comes to you if you refuse to correct it
that it's a bargain expensive as it is
it's a bargain right now if you do it
all the time people will correctly infer
that you're not doing thinking very well
because you're constantly having to
correct yourself but if you do your work
well so that you don't have to correct
yourself that often and then you do
correct yourself when you need to that
actually increases people's trust in you
because they know why you're trustworthy
which is that you'll fix it if you got
it wrong and you'll alert them right so
here's the crazy thing about that
I don't know how many times I've said
that but I've given that riff many many
times in many contexts I also believe
Sam has given that risk that riff almost
exactly right he has described this
process which means that at the very
least his conscious mind is aware of
this relationship
now
I think he's caught in a bind I think
Sam has two ideological commitments in
Conflict he's a little bit like Hal in
2001 that has two conflicting programs
um you remember that
yes yeah I just think that maybe the
first time that that those two
characters have been
um possibly compared to one another but
I think Sam has a belief in institutions
which I understand because frankly we're
really screwed if they don't work but
punchline they don't work I'm not a one
they're all busted and we're more
screwed if they don't work and most of
us are pretending that they do right
that's that's the worst of Both Worlds
so I think Sam has a desire to recognize
what's wrong with the institutions fix
them and get back to work and I think
the point is it's way later than you
think Sam those institutions are way
more corrupted than you understand
they're not coming back right and you
don't want any part of them because they
will do to you what they just did to you
with covid right they will mislead you
and they will turn you into a fool right
that's not what you want to do so at the
same time that he has a commitment to
the idea that institutions are the way
that we prevent Oblivion which I think
is not wrong right that we need
institutions that work to prevent us
from arranging Oblivion for ourselves
he's also committed to the idea that
when you get stuff wrong you should
correct it
and that these two things are in
competition and that his move this week
to leave is about one of these things
having won out over the other and it's
the exact wrong one these institutions
don't work they won't be rebooted and
trying you know rationalizing that
they're still close enough to functional
that you can invest more in them and
maybe you know put them right is not a
viable thing and I think frankly the
alternative that the institutions are so
far gone that you should do a proper
accounting correct your model and
apologize for what you got wrong explain
how it happened and rejoin the
conversation is the right thing to do
and Sam has headed 180 degrees away from
it yeah he chose the wrong alternative
at this moment instead of absenting
himself from this conversation he should
pay the price of getting back into
reality space
and he should move forward and he should
contribute to the conversation as he did
and you know affecting people the way he
has affected good friends of ours
um by altering their understanding of
the world that would be the right thing
to do and I you know I hope that some
time contemplating this off of Twitter
causes him to realize that and you know
again I the whole people if he does do
the right thing here people will be
generous to him and they will you know
not fail to notice how wrong he got
things but understand how it is that
that happened
um I think that would be
really important
[Music]